Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
As you can tell from the grey speckled walls
behind me, I have found myself, in a stunning
turn of events, in an airport.
I've actually been stuck in the airport for
a couple hours, Hank, because my flight is
delayed, and also because I love airports!
But anyway Hank, I've been thinking about
The Art Assignment.
One Art Assignment in particular, Jace Clayton's
The Quietest Place.
For those of you who don't know, The Art Assignment's
a cool show produced by PBS about contemporary
arts, starring my wife, and to a much lesser
extent, myself.
Jace's assignment was for us to take a walk
until we found the quietest place within walking
distance.
Right now I can hear two separate TVs and
some children.
And quiet is an interesting thing to talk
about on YouTube because attention has become
so fractured on the internet that there is
no longer room in YouTube videos for ANY silence.
Like Hank, I go back and I watch our videos
from 2007 with the jump cuts that are really,
really slow.
And this space between the jump cuts is just
absolutely unbearable.
Like in those 3 silent frames, I think to
myself, "I might not survive until the end
of this video."
And in the many hundreds of responses to Jace
Clayton's Art Assignment I saw this again,
and again.
People would be walking to their quietest
places, as I am now, and they would talk the
entire time.
It's only getting louder; this isn't working
at all.
The other thing I noticed, Hank, is that people's
quietest places are incredibly loud.
Usually it was loud with nature sounds, which
is fascinating, because it means on some level,
and I think this is true, we don't think of
nature sounds as being, like, sounds.
We think of them as kind of a loud-quiet.
No, this won't work, I can still hear the
TV.
Anyway, it all made me think about on the
internet, and maybe even outside of it, quiet
can feel kind of discomforting.
Just to get even through a few seconds of
quiet requires this intensity of focus that
we're not used to having to summon.
You know who knows the quietest place in an
airport?
TSA employees on a break.
Okay, Hank, here we are, as far as I can tell,
the quietest place in the entire Indianapolis
International Airport, where by gate A4, the
carpet looks like this, and now Hank, together,
we are going to enjoy and/or suffer through
a minute of silence together, alone with our
thoughts.
I can hear so much more than I could when
I sat down.
Hank, happy VidCon, I'll see you on Friday.